imaginez que cette île à 160 km de la
métropole devienne un pays à part
entière d'abord la corse dans la
république évidemment la corse reste
française restera française c'est un
sujet qui embarrasse les gouvernements
successifs depuis plusieurs années
maintenant pourtant nous sommes prêts à
discuter d'une possible l'autonomie le
ministre de l'intérieur est prêt à
parler d'autonomie avec les dirigeants
corses mais la frange la plus radicale
des élus elle va jusqu'à parler
d'indépendance alors est ce que l'île de
beauté pourrait survivre sans la france
et quelle différence y at-il entre
l'autonomie et l'indépendance réponse
dans facture
[Applaudissements]
la corse c'est à peu près trois cent
quarante mille habitants soit 0 25% de
la population française et 0 38% du pib
du pays avant tout il faut comprendre
que la corse bénéficie déjà d'une
certaine autonomie que lui confère
depuis 2018 son statut de collectivité
territoriale à statut particulier c'est
l'article 72 de la constitution
elle compte deux principales
institutions l'assemblée de corse et le
conseiller exécutif et elle dispose de
certaines compétences renforcées
permettant certaine adaptation du droit
traduction elle dispose déjà d'une
grande autonomie en matière économique
ou d'éducation par exemple mais bel
ensemble ils doivent conseils
s'appliquent en force de la même façon
eux dans les régions
de scénario bien différent
d'émancipation entre alors en jeu d'un
côté l'autonomie sur le modèle de
certaines communautés d'outre-mer c'est
l'article 74 de la constitution comme
saint barthélémy où la polynésie
française qui dispose de véritables
compétences législatives dans des
domaines tels que la santé la couverture
sociale ou la fiscalité même pas
l'autonomie important
adapter
un droit de veto en quelques heures
surtout à qui serait votée par le
parlement parmi les autonomistes corses
laisserai par contre l'état gérait tout
ce qui touche aux régaliens comme
l'armée la police la justice ou la
défense
mais le cas le plus radical concerne
l'indépendance totale qui exclut le
pouvoir central de la france et là ça se
corse normalement il faudrait un
référendum de l'ensemble de la
population française ils voteraient pour
décider si elle continuait à croire
à un détail près si pour eux garder le
même niveau de vie est un critère
capitale alors oui effectivement ils
doivent garder une relation forte avec
la métropole et grinder est directeur
des études économiques à l'université
catholique de lille en 2018 il publier
une étude sur la viabilité économique de
l'île si elle devenait indépendante il
s'apprête à publier une mise à jour de
la situation en 2022 qui l'a détaillera
figure life
je veux partager mon écran
le constat il est à changer l'économie
corse est particulière par exemple il y
à bourg tiers du produit intérieur brut
qui est la somme de l'administration de
la défense et du secteur non marchand ce
secteur qui est fait les soins de santé
l'action sociale c'est un secteur qui
est très caractérisée par des
financements publics par exemple part de
l'industrie manufacturière est
extrêmement faible dans le pays paie
concrètement ça veut dire que d'une
ville qui doit importer qu'est ce que la
plupart des biens qu'elles consomment ou
utilisent toi tu en provenance de la
métropole française ce soit dans les
autres pays du monde si c'était un pays
à belize on ouvrait avec un très gros
déficit extérieur autrement dit sans les
transferts de la métropole la corse
aurait beaucoup de mal à financer tous
ces services publics et elles devraient
renégocier tous les traités commerciaux
une indépendance complète sans plus
aucun financement en provenance de la
métropole voire même de l'union
européenne ce que tu helmand la position
officielle de l'union européenne qu'elle
avait d'ailleurs encore appelé pour les
causes qu'elle avait rappelé pour la
catalogne c'est que toutes régions d'un
état membre qui quitteraient c'était
dame en boubou devenir un nouveau pays
indépendant ne 2 après pas du tout de
plein droit à 28e est un membre de
l'union européenne
ça signifierait une sortie européenne et
une sortie de l'euro en plus de ça la
corse affiche le sixième pib le plus bas
des régions françaises et se place au
quatrième rang des régions les plus
touchées par le chômage un autre
handicap de lille c'est un pourcentage
de personnes peu qualifiées est
relativement important il part trop
grande de gens qui n'ont même pas le bac
ce problème de presque un quart de la
population en âge de travailler qui
semble manquer qualification pour
pouvoir obtenir un travail bien rémunéré
malgré cette grande dépendance à la
métropole quelles seraient alors les
secteurs clés qui profiterait à la corse
quels sont ses points forts c'est
certainement sa situation déjà stratégie
dans leur année on pense tout de suite
au tourisme mais sachant que la corse a
toujours refusé une trop grande
massification de son tourisme qui
mènerait où bp tonnerre je suis
biologiste de sa cote est d'ailleurs
bien raison de le faire les sabines et
d'avoir pu préserver la nature en
matière de défense il pourrait monnayer
éventuellement la mise à disposition
certains ports mille de chypre par
exempe à de grandes bases britanniques
et lagardelle l'époque coloniale
[Musique]
d'ailleurs les corses se disent plutôt
oui à l'autonomie et non à
l'indépendance selon la dernière enquête
de l'ifop 53% des français adhèrent à
l'idée d'un statut d'autonomie pour la
corse cela monte à 73 % pour les
résidents corses et des continentaux aux
origines corses en revanche la
perspective d'indépendance reste
majoritairement rejetée par 60% de
l'opinion publique et seuls 32% des
résidents corses y sont favorables même
si le nombre de partisans de
l'indépendance a doublé en 30 ans et
quand même un processus qui a très peu
de chance de céder de la paix pour une
raison bien simple les mouvements
indépendants puissent le port reste
malgré l'argument milliards de paires ou
simples vacances en 2018 déjà emmanuel
macron tracé cette ligne rouge la
république doit conserver cette ambition
de ménage et à la corse un avenir qui
soit à la hauteur de ses espérances
sans transiger avec les requêtes qui la
ferait sortir du giron républicain
comment expliquer alors ce sentiment
grandissant au sein du peuple corse dans
un entretien à filière au vox le
géographe laurent chalard interprète la
montée des revendications régionales
comme lié à l'affaissement de l'identité
nationale selon lui beaucoup de français
ne s'y reconnaissent plus ressentant
ainsi le besoin d'un ancrage nouveau
d'une identité
[Musique]